Vous êtes entouré par le mystère et ces rêves...
des gens qui ont cru en ces disques.
Imaginez les milliers d’artistes destinés à devenir des légendes,
mais qui, pour diverses raisons, ont été oubliés.
Bon nombre de ces disques n’existent qu'en quelques unités,
et certains n’ont même jamais été retrouvés,
jamais écoutés.
C’est littéralement des espèces en voie de disparition.
Je vais vous raconter une histoire
qui pour moi, résume en quelque sorte la valeur du travail des collectionneurs.
L’histoire d’un brillant musicien et compositeur montréalais.
Henri-Pierre Noël est né et a grandi à Haïti,
il a vécu brièvement aux États-Unis et en Belgique.
Il est passé par Montréal pour n'y rester que deux semaines,
mais il a fini par y vivre 40 ans.
Quand il était jeune, il jouait du piano,
et a développé une façon particulière de jouer :
rapidement, comme des percussions.
Son style était un mélange de folklore et d’influences haïtiennes
avec des influences américaines entendues pendant son enfance.
Il a donc créé un mélange de musiques à base de funk et de jazz.
Jeune,
il jouait avec des groupes live aux États-Unis et en Europe,
mais il n’avait jamais enregistré un album avant de vivre au Canada.
C’est à Montréal en 1979
qu’il sort son premier album, « Piano ».
Entièrement seul, chez Henri-Pierre Noël Records.
Il n’a fait que ce qu’il pouvait : soit 2 000 copies du disque.
Le disque est même passé un peu à l’antenne,
un peu de soutien au Canada et à Haïti,
mais sans un gros label derrière,
c’était très, très difficile.
À l’époque,
si votre disque ne passait pas à la radio,
s’il ne passait pas dans les jukebox, ou à la télé,
les chances de réussir étaient minces.
Sortir un album en tant qu’artiste indépendant
était plus difficile qu’aujourd’hui,
à la fois en termes de diffusion et de distribution.
Peu de temps après, il sortit un deuxième album.
Il jouait du piano dans plusieurs clubs de la ville,
mais ses disques ont lentement pris la poussière.
Et ces 2 000 copies, en 30 ans,
se sont facilement perdues
jusqu’à ce qu’il n'en reste plus que quelques exemplaires dans le monde.
Puis au milieu des années 2000,
un disquaire de Montréal du nom de Kobal
faisait sa tournée hebdomadaire de chasse aux disques.
Il était dans un marché aux puces
entouré de milliers de disques sales, poussiéreux et moisis.
C’est là qu’il a trouvé l’album « Piano ».
Il ne le cherchait pas spécifiquement.
En fait, on pourrait dire que le disque l’a trouvé.
On pourrait aussi dire qu’après 20 ans de fouille de disques toutes les semaines,
il a développé un sixième sens pour dénicher des pépites.
Il a pris le disque et l’a inspecté :
la couverture, l’arrière, les notes d'accompagnement.
Il était intrigué par le fait que ce musicien haïtien ait fait un disque
au Québec à la fin des années 70,
donc il était intrigué.
Il a amené son petit tourne-disque portable
qu’il emporte quand il part en quête.
Et il a écouté le disque.
Alors, pourquoi ne pas faire la même chose ?
(Musique)
Il est tombé amoureux de la musique instantanément,
mais il voulait connaître son histoire.
Il ne savait pas d’où elle venait.
Il savait que l’artiste,
lors de l’enregistrement,
vivait à Montréal,
alors très longtemps, il a tenté de le retrouver.
Il a trouvé la carte de visite de Noël dans la pochette du disque.
C’était la façon de faire de Henri-Pierre Noël.
Il a trouvé la carte dans la pochette du disque.
Bien sûr, il a tenté d’appeler,
mais après 30 ans, le numéro ne marchait plus.
Ce fut donc seulement en Belgique,
où l’artiste avait aussi vécu,
que Kobal trouva quelqu’un qui connaissait personnellement l’artiste.
Et lui donna le contact.
Alors quand il s’est enfin assis avec l’artiste,
il lui a promis de trouver un jour un moyen de ressortir l’album.
Il a ensuite vu avec un label britannique appelé Wah Wah 45
pour rééditer les deux albums.
Et ce qui arrive très souvent,
dans ces projets de réédition,
c’est qu’il devient difficile de trouver des cassettes de qualité
de l’enregistrement original du disque.
L’art peut être détruit par différentes intempéries naturelles,
jeté à la poubelle,
ou juste perdu à jamais.
Mais heureusement,
les cassettes d’Henri-Pierre Noël étaient en sécurité
et prêtes à être remastérisées.
Le disque a finalement été réédité
et a reçu les éloges de critiques, de DJ et d’auditeurs du monde entier,
les éloges qu’il aurait dû recevoir en 1979.
Ça a inspiré l’artiste au point de relancer sa carrière musicale,
de retourner sur scène et de jouer pour un nouveau public.
L’artiste, maintenant dans la soixantaine,
m’a dit : « Cela a tout changé pour moi.
Je me préparais pour la retraite
et je me retrouve à jouer pour la BBC à Londres et pour Radio Canada. »
Ça lui a aussi donné la chance de jouer
devant ses trois fils pour la première fois.
Pour moi, cette histoire montre le travail de collectionneur de disques à son top.
Au-delà de la rareté et de la valeur monétaire
(et je vais être honnête, on est complètement obsédés par ça)
la vraie beauté est de donner une seconde chance à l’art ;
pour le sauver de l’oubli.
Le travail d’un bon collectionneur est une boucle de trois phases.
La première est la chasse.
On passe des heures, des jours, des années de notre vie
à fouiller dans des bacs à disques sales et poussiéreux.
On fait tout ce qu’on peut pour dénicher des pépites.
Oui, on peut trouver de bons disques en ligne,
mais pour les trésors cachés,
vous devez quitter le canapé et sortir chercher.
On est des collectionneurs de disques, pas de clics.
(Rires)
On est des archéologues de la musique.
La deuxième étape consiste à se réunir
en fonction de nos goûts et de notre expertise,
on choisit soigneusement les disques à sauver,
ceux qui nous tiennent à cœur.
On essaie ensuite de découvrir tout ce qu’on peut sur ce disque,
l’artiste, le label
et des infos super importantes
comme « Qui joue la trompette sur la piste 3 ? »
Ensuite on les classe, on les contextualise,
et on les protège.
On est archivistes de musique.
Et la dernière étape de la boucle, c’est le partage.
La plupart des collectionneurs que je connais ont une sorte de moyen
faire partager leur découverte et élever l’artiste
par une réédition d’album,
un article sur le web, une émission de radio.
On redonne aux disques leur juste place dans l’histoire de la musique.
On découvre et on préserve.
Nous sommes musicologues.
Quant à moi
et les collectionneurs que j’ai rencontrés en 20 ans,
je pense que c’est une sorte d’exutoire,
toutes ces découvertes.
Je pense que c’est notre façon de rester sain et de sentir utile
dans cette obsession très exaspérante,
qui peut être une quête solitaire.
Je pense qu’on le fait aussi, car ça répond au besoin humain
de transmettre le savoir culturel.
En parlant du besoin de préservation,
à une époque de choix pléthorique,
il a été démontré
que trop de choix gêne la découverte.
Par exemple,
si vous essayez de regarder quelque chose sur Netflix,
vous parcourez un catalogue de seulement 6 000 titres.
Comparez ça avec Spotify.
Si vous voulez choisir quelque chose à écouter,
vous parcourez un catalogue de 30 millions de chansons.
Donc vous pouvez voir
que cette paralysie par abondance
touche la musique plus que le cinéma,
par exemple.
Il y a quelques études
qui commencent à en montrer les effets.
Un regard sur le marché musical au Royaume-Uni
montre que seulement 1 % des artistes gagnent en fait 77 %
des revenus totaux de l’industrie de la musique.
C’était en 2013,
et cela s’aggrave progressivement
ou progresse.
Si vous êtes dans les 1 %, vous êtes surement content.
(Rires)
Ce qu’il faut retenir,
c’est qu’il est plus facile pour les gens d’écouter de la musique qu’avant.
Les gens ont plus de musique à leur disposition qu’avant,
mais les gens choisissent d’écouter plus de musique du même genre.
Et c’est triste.
Mû par mon amour pour la recherche, les disques et la préservation,
j’ai lancé un site web appelé « Music Is My Sanctuary » en 2007.
Notre slogan a toujours été « Futurs classiques et trésors oubliés ».
Et il montre notre amour pour la découverte musicale
et présente de la musique ancienne et nouvelle.
Depuis nos humbles débuts,
on a construit une plateforme mondiale avec un large public
de plus de 100 collaborateurs.
On a créé plus de 10 000 morceaux de contenu,
plus de 500 heures de contenu audio.
Notre public se compose de gens
qui veulent plus que le contenu proposé par les chaînes commerciales de musique.
Ils veulent creuser plus,
mais ils n’ont pas 20 heures par semaine comme nous,
donc ils nous font confiance pour faire ça pour eux.
La curation est au cœur de notre activité.
On croit plus aux avis humains que les algorithmes.
Je pourrais parler de ma passion pendant des heures,
mais laissez-moi conclure ainsi.
Après des années de travail,
la collection de disques devient la biographie du collectionneur.
L’année dernière, j’étais DJ en Pologne,
et les gens qui m’accueillaient,
avaient une grande collection de disques,
et bien sûr, j’étais intrigué
et j’ai dit : « Vous vendez ça ? »
Ils m’ont ensuite expliqué que c’était la collection
de leur cher ami Maceo, décédé quelques mois plus tôt.
Ils avaient pour projet d’inviter différentes personnes
de prendre la collection et d’en créer quelque chose de nouveau,
que ce soit de l’échantillonnage ou des mixes,
pour lui donner une seconde vie.
Après quelques heures à parcourir sa collection,
et à créer un mix,
même si je n’ai jamais pu le rencontrer,
c’était comme si, d’une manière spéciale,
lui et moi,
on avait parlé de disques pendant quelques heures.
Alors, en tant que collectionneur de disques,
notre travail et nos disques sont là
pour être transmis à la prochaine génération.
L’art mérite d’être chéri, partagé et redécouvert.
Il faut préserver ;
nous sommes la voie alternative aux grandes chaînes musicales,
numériques ou autres.
Allez au-delà de l’algorithme.
Quel que soit votre genre de musique,
il y a tellement de sites web, d’émissions, de DJs, de magasins,
qui attendent de partager leurs découvertes avec vous.
On fait ce travail pour vous.
Il vous suffit d’ouvrir les oreilles et de prendre des risques.
Cette musique changera votre vie.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)